may is asian pacific american heritage
month and first on cbs this morning we
are revealing a record-breaking
investment in
aapi causes the asian american
foundation
is being launched today with 125 million
dollars in funding that is the biggest
commitment ever
by asian americans into their own
community it comes as a new report shows
that
anti-asian hate crimes surged more than
160 percent
in the first three months of 2021
compared with the same period last year
sonal shah is the foundation's president
and actor and producer daniel day kim is
co-chair of
of the founding advisory council good
morning to both of you this is a very
big deal 125 million
uh sonal first question to you as the
founding president of this organization
what do you plan to do with that money
well good morning and it's so great to
be here and
uh welcome to asian pacific heritage
month it's fantastic
we are going we are an incubator a
convener and a funder
so when we think about where we want to
fund one we want to fund
hate anti-hate crimes want to make sure
that we're supporting our communities
want to make sure we're supporting the
organizations that have been doing all
the work on the ground
two we want to fund data and research
data and research we need to know what's
happening in our communities and make
sure we can fund it so
we're going to fund data and research
and through education we want to make
sure
asian-american education is part of the
american story
and that's really our focus and so why
is this coming out
now was it something in the works prior
to the past 12 to 14 months of these
really public and awful incidents uh
attacks on asian americans but we've
been watching the
sorry daniel we've been watching the
anti-asian hate incidents
and we've been watching what's been
happening last year and realized that we
needed to create an organization and our
board
and our chairman especially lee liu
really took the initiative and said we
need to bring people together and make
sure we're funding and so we did that
and when when atlanta happened we went
into action even faster we were just
doing strategy and we're like we have to
launch
now and our board committed 125
million dollars i mean that's an
incredible investment on their part
uh to asian american causes daniel what
does this money need to go to urgently
do you think what's the most important
agenda here
well i think given what uh the community
has been going through
uh you know the initial investments uh
have been going to
organizations that are uh dedicated to
uh
stopping anti-asian hate uh there have
been a number of investments already
placed
and all of them are to try to to help
our local communities uh
battle some of these issues that we're
facing you know
when you talk about what the community
has been going through daniel it's
heartbreaking and also blood boiling at
the same time
i'm wondering about you personally has
it changed how you move in the world
these days
do you find that you are concerned for
your own safety
or people that you care about does it
change how you move
it has changed uh some things you know
my parents
are in california i have uh you know a
sister who's had her own experience with
uh anti-asian violence
uh and uh you know i have kids so
it you know seeing the number of people
and
the kind of people who have been
attacked over the past year has really
uh affected how how i see
uh our ability to move around and be
free and to be considered america
yeah what do you do differently you know
uh you know for instance my wife my wife
doesn't
doesn't like to travel alone anymore
she's she makes sure that she's always
with a friend
uh it's the same with my parents i make
sure that they're
traveling together or with friends and
you know when they're walking in cities
like new york
or los angeles they make sure that
they're
not that they're not wearing headphones
uh or ipods and
or you know earbuds and they're always
aware of their surroundings at all times
daniel even as we keep these concerns
front of mind and
sonal i'd love you to weigh in on this
as well it's interesting that you say we
should
uh not only mark asian american heritage
month but celebrate it
keyword celebrate uh why do you put that
in the foreground
daniel you go well actually son will you
go first and then we'll go back to
daniel
sorry i should be directing traffic
sonal go ahead
i think it's so important to recognize
that we are such a diverse community
of asian americans we are 40 different
ethnicities 20 different pacific
islander communities
that we need to celebrate who we are too
it's always it's always easy to not
recognize that we all live very we have
very different
uh backgrounds experiences and we live
different lives but we are also asian
american and we have very similar
experiences and many stories
many cases what you heard from daniel is
probably what you're going to hear from
a lot of people and the experiences that
they've had
so we need to celebrate ourselves also
and not just be
not just be nazi and we want to make
sure people know who we are and that we
are part of telling the american story
all right daniel last word goes to you
how will you be celebrating this month
uh plenty of ways there there are a lot
of things that uh that i'll be
doing personally using my platforms for
instance anyone
who uh decides to show some asian pride
on their tick tock or their instagram or
our facebook are are going to be
retweeted by me you'll be hearing from
vlad uta
[Laughter]
and i think that they're just a number
of great ways that organizations like
taft
uh are coming together and planning
events uh
around uh celebrating us because as
sonos said so eloquently
you know there there's a lot that we're
going through that's that's not
necessarily
positive in our community but we have a
lot to celebrate because we are proud to
be
american well we'll be sure to do some
more celebrating too so
daniel day kim we thank you both for
joining us you're watching cbs
this morning